[Music]
this week we've got to the Booga 4x and
escape bill take it away first story
people found out that Google Translate
isn't accurate
it's friendly like my tattoo is [ __ ]
up
no it'll translate gibberish as Somali
why Booga Wooga yeah it's like Somali
suppose that's about right oh I thought
it was really Somali oh no some people
Paco that's rude right no but it's not
perfect
come on they're [ __ ] up because they
know nobody in Somalia has the interwebs
I made that up I don't know if they do
because they're pirates not everyone is
a pirate there Wow so back in 2014
someone on 4chan discovered this I don't
think anything's wrong with the in
pirate so in October 2014 someone said
number one go to Google Translate to
translate from Somali to English 3 write
something along the lines of Booga Booga
Ooga Booga Booga 4 it actually
translated into complex English words
I'm not making this up what did it
translate it to well who's the [ __ ]
loser who has no life to figure that
[ __ ] out what the [ __ ] 13 year olds that
spend a lot of time either jacking off
we're doing random [ __ ] online recently
this went viral
thanks to this tweet and it's a video it
says Google Translate got ass bucked up
BAM what the [ __ ] and so it's very video
how fam is it's like the term now
everybody calls everybody family huh
hello fam what's up with that van I
don't know fam use the [ __ ] is lame what
bad let's do this van Ness
I love the [ __ ] I have the honor of
being my husband wait though that [ __ ]
wasn't not that funny
these [ __ ] are hi-yah example
of here they wrote I'm done
Booga Booga Ooga Booga Wooga Wooga and
keep your duty to Allah oh it would be
weird is there somebody Somali decide oh
that's exactly what it says I don't know
what you're saying like you should hire
me to translate like they're actually Oh
key Bugaboo guru no I do not be fooled
that's what Google hired me to fix your
challenge because you're so mollies
broker than my wallets bad Somali they
smell they spelled us some they are the
Somalis it seems like based on this
tweet did you guys see Captain Phillips
no there's a movie though I am ducati
now oh I want to watch it but I keep
forgetting I did watch it all right that
was hoping all of you guys said yes I
could be like oh tell me about it is
that the one with the Tom Hanks yes you
the captain of a ship that gets taken
over the cargo ship I want to watch it
I think it's splitting the country the
movie no the country of Somalia it's
it's turning into two
why is it sound like you must be
famished
I don't know I don't know how to use the
slang yet and when I get to know this
thing I'll use it better
I'm like the country don't you ever
really call us ma'am like when you write
hey fat but it's not the same way that
these guys I've never seen David say
that really yeah Pam is like UK slang
isn't it or like I heard people in
Kannada say it a lot our fans calls us
the JK fan yeah I call us the JK that's
a proper way I understand that much hand
fan
someone called someone Jen them no I
just made that up I like that yeah chan
phan we should get it to yeah see if you
Casey Isaac I think I'll have a chant
can I like that to the parents and
brother and like that's like all of us
Oh cartoon called the Chan clan right
yeah I like the Tang Clan that sounds
more race with the musical music obey
the 10 clan yeah I see a lot of rice and
cleaver tattoos on your chest right I
like using a fan Bam Bam Bam yeah how
would you how would you use famine yeah
I'm seeing out the fan down bambam I've
written that before I don't say it
that's my fam BAM that's true those are
the things that you write you don't say
there's a text talk and then there's a
all I could like a human talk like where
people communicate like lol but I'm
never laughing out loud I just write lol
well your face is like yeah that's
really funny if I put our o rofl and
that's when I just smile I'm like I'm
expressing don't cuz I actually laugh I
write if I'm really laughing then it's
hhhh hhhh got the caca
I like that
booga-booga-booga I mean I am honored to
be your husband
yeah I'm honored to be your husband no
I'm honored honored to be my husband
right the other side yeah so Google is
spokesperson for Google said that
inappropriate translations can be
reported and that they said that when
Google Translate generates a translation
it uses patterns for millions of
translations to help decide on the best
translation for you so they're saying
that they're just constantly working on
improving and then by the time that this
article was posted they had already
changed the whole Google Buddha all that
stuff but it seems like it's not even
like mistranslation it just seems like
they missed an entire language yeah that
was an OP it was probably like a secret
like a video game password code no other
saying that they liked the way Google
Translate works is by looking at any
language that the words entered me sound
like and then it proceeds to guess what
the term is oh I see yeah so that's that
they kind of had like three years to to
work on it cuz then the first time it
was reported was in 2014 right well that
was on 410 so I didn't really go viral
or anything for our next story this
pepper called pepper X is said to be the
new world's hottest pepper what's this
called oh is it man-made yes so the same
so previously so this still hasn't been
officially crowned the most like the
hottest pepper yet but the one that's
still holding the title is number one is
the Carolina Reaper which I ate what we
really I thought it was like something
with like a dragon's dragon's breath
well that's the current unofficial what
would people eat stuff call Besh's make
a party dude and they're supposed to be
seasonings they're supposed to put one
in like a big-ass [ __ ] pot of
crawfish or something no it's just crazy
people are crazy they just I get the
[ __ ] ass paper please thank you well
so the Carolina Reaper is 1.6 million
and this pepper X apparently is 3.18
million Oh God
do you
want to die pepper yeah yeah they're
saying that this is actually not
available
it's not available for everyone to just
get the only way you can taste this is
in this sauce that's called hot ones the
last dab and so this sauce is the only
sauce that actually contains it because
they're saying that this pepper is so
extreme that it will actually trick your
body into thinking you're actually on
fire it would make your body think
you're dead the thing that they have it
in how do they get it that sauce oh the
Creator so the creator of the Carolina
Reapers the same creator that made this
pepper and so well the Carolina Reaper
it looks like a yellow Carolina Reaper
oh my bad though the Carolina Reaper it
pretty much is okay it makes you
internally
well raper sounds better though yeah it
looks like a yellow version of the
Carolina Reaper yeah it does that looks
like Tigers poop right now mustard
yellow because of the breast feeding the
breast milk so this is apparently the
most hottest spiciest thing ever you can
possibly have I don't even want to try
it no no I love complex what did they
say so complex they did a video where
they it's called don't believe me hot
the hype like this little segment that
they had like it's not too spicy is that
what is that what they say yeah so then
the host of this show he ended up going
around conflicts like all the employees
so I can try this last dab sauce on
these hot wings and so I want to show
you just a little clip of their
reactions on the show like fire yes it's
made from pepper X which is twice as hot
as the Carolina Reaper Cheers
why people can't hang with spice I
thought that was a job one does to drink
that Wow got a drink I know someone like
that you gotta wait like five minutes
though oh yeah
I see a little glow I feel a little
glossy I mean there's a little bit spicy
but not as oh my god early 2000
references so they're saying that this a
sauce is really tricky because at first
it makes it seem like it's like oh yeah
it's spicy if it's not that bad I can
handle it and then it tricks you into
thinking like I can have some more oh
wow are these people that were trying it
they put like two more times or three
much then they made the wrong city
called the Chinese businessman you think
she tried you think you could trust them
but later he [ __ ] you up why why it
like is it just like people just want to
[ __ ] just try it to try it like a
novelty thing I think there's a lot of
people that are into spicy stuff like
that yeah I went through a phase in
junior high where I was trying to find
the spiciest sauces and always
challenged my buddies and do stuff like
that
I don't like spice I like the taste of
peppers yeah that's what I like they
have an awesome taste to them like
that's why I'd like Szechuan [ __ ] too
it's just the numbers your whole [ __ ]
mouth and then you bleed out your ass I
just don't like the bleeding part I like
the pepper flavor I don't like the pain
part of it yeah man like I don't know at
a certain age too I guess like I can't
process like spicy foods and cream food
tends to be a little bit spicy too like
90% of it is spicy yeah and so like I
just I just get [ __ ] at the end I
still eat it and I just deal with it the
next day they're saying that this one
you can really type tampons from as well
continue really taste like the flavor
because they they put like mustard and I
don't know what else to put in this
thing but they're just saying like a
super flavorful braid just locks you up
with like the captain
capsaicin Jason thank you yeah I know I
was missing something you think I
remember when we did Jake a party and we
had to Eve all a ghost pepper Carolina
Reaper and [ __ ] habanero and yeah by
the time we got to the jalapeno it was
like a bell pepper it was there was no
spice anymore none at all that [ __ ] is
dangerous though because if you get it
on your hand and like your hands just
moist and it just [ __ ] stains that
[ __ ]
it was so spicy that I to go to sleep so
I went to sleep late and I woke up with
half of my face red yeah and burning how
do you get rid of that oil then I should
have washed my hands but I don't know
that's why I brought my whatever part of
my hand that touched the spice was sort
like it ate like the skin or something
it was not we should wear gloves like
you put that inside your body
yeah stupidly that's not I don't know
about you but like my my Bohol it was
yeah that substance is awesome dude I
don't know about you but my butthole is
reap'd I know you have training I don't
know I got trained for that [ __ ] early
days but god damn that was really [ __ ]
me I couldn't follow those peppers I and
I just swallowed my saliva and even that
hurt my stomach yeah I don't think I'm
gonna do that again for a long time all
right for our last story there was this
man who was trying to get away from his
hotel bill by climbing through the wires
and hunt me outside so you guys guess
where this takes place the wires on the
outside yeah like telephone wires
I have no idea about the UK or who what
what like what kind of person would want
to run away from their bill Asian China
yeah oh my god be so racist like that
yeah I'm the China person and not once
and I think China I did look like you
were because you're like oh that could
have been a white person I was not
thinking China for the first time a
white person yeah anyone would have done
that you guys know anything I'm just
nobody's [ __ ] probably wouldn't you
know we've got China bro oh my god
that's [ __ ] spider-man is that flying
out the window oh you're just doing
parkour so the wires oh that's funny you
know something recording that well he's
trying to get away try that we all
discrete and [ __ ] show you yeah I would
have recorded it cuz I would be like
cool they're like practicing what is
that the tightrope I thought this school
died yeah luckily this guy survived and
he didn't electrocute dude that was like
willing to risk his life so he doesn't
have to pay the bill which was the bill
I don't know $29.99 even if I caught the
guy I just let him go cuz it's like he
deserves I think you earned it
that's not good that should be the hotel
deal you don't have to pay for your room
if you do this [ __ ] here's all the
Mission Impossible Zeron even can join
and said thank you same time look at
this dump function maybe I should be
faster $29 beer but out there punk later
they don't think I know that she's not
going back
he's like scary or do you think people
saw him he's like
like there's just a lot of people on the
street wait was that a person or a
[ __ ] siren I know these a lady that's
gotta be [ __ ] scariest [ __ ] I can't
imagine doing that you know on a rope
just with their bare hands it's not even
a rope what is all that even meant to be
climbed on you know look what you're
doing break or anything did you have to
pay the bill afterwards natural thing
they were reporting like it's not clear
whether or not the hotel let him slide
for this I wouldn't have I would be like
I'm gonna charge you double for [ __ ]
why do you think he couldn't pay or do
you think he's just too cheap I maybe he
left this caught his wallet in an uber
so this was 19 stories above ground oh
my god two stories above ground I'd be
shittin bricks like crazy what if that
was his thing though he went from hotel
to hotel to stay and when he's done he
just sneaks out he asks for a room
that's kind of can I get that electrical
wire room please like oh I will never
ask what happy for he knows like each
room number for each other
that's a hotel special right there did
the wire special damn there's a mic he
got tangled up and stuck on the wires
and then that's when he decided and go
back after you because he was scared it
was just like oh it's not possible I had
an obstruction and then he had a go back
in so he had to end up going back into
his room oh it's hard going harder going
back to cuts on an incline so coming
down was easier to go back oopsie I
didn't think this one if I was him I
think I would try to do everything for
free because obviously he ain't got no
money
right so he's willing to risk his life
for like the the lowest amount all right
what if you rent a car how do you get
out of that rent a car yeah what do you
do then I don't return it I climb out
and run away you just leave I just sign
up with fake information cuz this guy
does things like he could he could
literally just walk out the hotel that's
you right
like what
I don't like what why didn't like any
just walk like walk away yeah what
happened yeah I don't know but then so
everything I do it's gonna be life
threatening to get away maybe I just
crash it into something and then run
away maybe that's what he remembered
awfully oh yeah he just got that that
that paper that went under the door is
it's time to check out of course away
though man they're not gonna stop you
right like they're just gonna say like
have a nice day and you're gonna go out
yeah well it's not that
let's not like they even know that your
face is like renting there you know what
I mean like you can visit or you've
already checked out for all they know
yeah you just walk out and never come
back
wait don't they take your credit card
yeah so it'll be charged after the day
is done maybe not in China I don't know
maybe they maybe it's a cache hotel I
don't know but it's just it's just
ridiculous I'm deep story cash hotel
that's crazy
I'm just like why don't you just walk
away what's why is it so hard or maybe
they were like this [ __ ]
isn't gonna pay out don't let him leave
the room unless like and then everyone's
watching him cuz he hasn't paid in the
last three days or whatever someone is
young I have so many questions I'm like
why can't you a foyer why did you stay
into a hotel that you can't pay for yeah
I want to know what he looks like -
because I feel like only ugly people do
that well I never know other means to
get money
I just don't big handsome people do that
have you ever seen like a good-looking
criminal yes yeah that model guy he's
not really a crypt but he's not climbing
out of windows yeah he's just beating
wives and stuff right wait what was this
thing so me well like he had a gun he
had oh yeah we could we read the face
yeah come on now thanks for watching
guys and those are our thoughts what are
your thoughts don't forget to comment
below we want to know what you guys are
thinking but don't write anything that
will make it sad or make us mad because
after all we're just kidding news and
we're a very happy channel for the last
video click up here
[Music]